hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich bin froh dass ich jetzt endlich
geschafft habe mal dieses video zu
machen und zwar möchte ich euch ein paar
ausschnitte zeigen aus der cache world
messe in friedrichshafen die schweiz
leider auch schon eine ganze weile her
habe ich auch bisher einfach nicht
geschafft auf und vor allem vielen
terminen und dann noch die
schwangerschaft da muss ich auch noch
wie viele videos drehen und ich wollte
einfach auch das video richtig schön
machen
vor allem möchte ich jetzt erst einmal
ein paar ausschnitte zeigen und später
dann doch ein bisschen wasser zu
erzählen
also echt umfasst viele zuschauer dieses
mal wieder da waren und wir haben diese
drei tage auch wirklich viel spaß
gemacht auch wenn sie immer sehr
anstrengend sind und ich am abend
wirklich immer fast tot ins bett
gefallen bin
aber es war sehr schön und was ich
besonders rührend fand viele haben mir
eben auch was mitgebracht und ich möchte
jetzt euch einfach mal zeigen was das
alles war okay jetzt hat sich mitten
drin und ich weiß echt sagt mir dass ich
dazu sagen soll
also eigentlich ist es nicht mal alles
was ich geschenkt bekommen habe ich hab'
noch viel viel mehr bekommen aus vieles
war eben auch was zum aufessen deswegen
ist es leider schon weg oder auch zum
glück waren viele leckere sachen mit
dabei aber bevor ich euch jetzt ein paar
sachen zeigen möchte ich euch echt darum
bitten dass sie mir einfach nichts
verschenkt und nichts mehr schickt ich
finde es wahnsinnig schön ich meine
jeder mensch findet es schön beschenkt
zu werden aber ich fühle mich dann halt
immer so verpflichtet ich möchte mich
natürlich dann auch bei jedem bedanken
und jedes geschenk dann auch eben auch
würdigen
danke brief zurück schreiben oder eine e
mail zurück schreiben aber ich komme da
leider nicht mehr dazu weil ich einfach
so viel zu tun habe und habe ich total
die schuldgefühle und fühle mich total
schlecht weil ihr euch so viel mühe
gegeben habt und ich eigentlich euch die
zeit gar nicht zurück schenken kann die
er mir im prinzip schenkt und ja da
fühle ich mich immer total schuldig also
bitte bitte schickt mir nichts mehr und
schenkt mir nix mehr bietet das wäre als
adresse für mich das größte was ihr tun
könnt aber ich möchte euch jetzt
trotzdem einfach mal ein paar sachen
zeigen viele dinge sind natürlich auch
für unser baby was bald auf die welt
kommt und einige sachen waren für samira
mit dabei für murat mit dabei was ich
noch zeigen möchte das weiß nicht von
der messe in friedrichshafen sondern von
weihnachten noch da bin ich nämlich
leider auch nicht dazu gekommen ich mal
zu bedanken und zwar hat mir das eine
liebe zuschauerin gehäkelt also das ist
wirklich der wahnsinn
sie hat mir lauter kleine törtchen
gehäkelt und kehren cupcake zum beispiel
alles noch extra beschriftet handschrift
alles ein laminiert ausgeschnitten also
ich glaub du sagst da wahrscheinlich
vier oder fünf tage dran
ich bin ja auch hauswirtschaftslehrerin
und ja wahnsinn
also ich finde es echt echt zucker nicht
sogar kunst sondern wahre kunst da sind
sogar hinten drin noch die passenden
pralinen und ich stelle es mal ganz kurz
hier ab so vielen vielen dank ihr
wirklich euch allen
ja was wollte ich jetzt noch zeigen hier
habe ich zum beispiel so eine kleine
kiste bekommen eben auch was das baby
mit dabei ist wahrscheinlich was für
samira so ein duschgel bisschen was für
mich dabei bat und peeling habe ich
nötig für die entspannung zwischendurch
also echt richtig schön was ich auch
super fand und da fühle ich mich auch
total schuldig weil das ist einfach aus
und richtig wunderschönes geschenk und
zwar gibt es ja auf den cache bolt
messen nicht nur meinen stand sondern
auch ganz viele andere stände und dabei
unter anderem auch der stand vom
schützen michel und zwar ist es ein ganz
liebes mädchen mit ihrer familie und die
hat mir diese schürze geschenkt und
diese stürze
also man könnte jetzt meinen was ist
daran so besonders außer dass sie so
toll aussieht das besondere daran ist
dass handgemacht und das auch noch von
ihrer mama und ich hab's nicht mal auf
der messe geschafft mich bei ihr zu
bedanken
das muss sich in wien auf jeden fall
sofort nachholen das ist eines der
ersten dinge die ich machen werde
ich habe zwar auch schürzen bei mir im
shop aber die kommen niemals an so eine
schürze dran weil das ist wirklich
handarbeit mit ganz viel liebe genäht
und mit viel liebe gemacht und farblich
passt es natürlich perfekt zur pinkel
liebenzell ii also das war natürlich
gleich mal ein volltreffer
und sobald ich die gewaschen und wieder
gebügelt hab ich habe sie leider etwas
zerknittert werdet ihr natürlich auch
mal tragen
betschel-pflügel von petra habe ich auch
mal der schütze bestellt genau das war
richtig schön ja ansonsten habe ich wie
gesagt viel fürs baby hier war sogar
noch was für die samira mit dabei
ich habe viele ist auch wieder
eingepackt denn ich wollte euch einfach
mal auch so die verpackungen und so
weiter zeigen der die schoko ich habe
schon gesagt das haben wir schon
aufgegessen seien
hier bitteschön
dann haben wir zum beispiel für samira
das finde ich auch ganz schön zum ersten
mal ein geschwisterchen
das haben wir noch nicht gelesen das
machen wir jetzt weil jetzt fängt ja die
zeit an wo wir es mir jetzt auch baby
vorbereiten müssen oder wollen clubs
hier noch ein kind guck mal wie hübsches
ist ein t shirt für die samira
totalschäden gelb muss man noch was nun
kann sie das auch anziehen
richtig schön was ich auch richtig süß
finde hinten hängt ja glaube ich auch
hinter mir eins genau
auch diese plakate die für mich gemacht
wurden mit sally und murat drauf und mit
samira mit drauf also richtig schön oder
was auch richtig schön war da wurde ich
auch ganz emotional beim lesen hieß es
was ist diese fälle gedicht von der
theresa teresa hat mich schon öfters
besucht auf messen und das gedicht ist
wirklich schön und es werde ich mir
sogar zuhause irgendwohin hängen weil ja
da steht ein ganz toller text drauf
stoppt den kann ich ja mal ab
fotografien und als foto einfügen
richtig schön und was ich hier auch noch
habe das fand ich auch richtig süß und
wenn man die geschichte dazu kennt dann
als ich glaube ich fast weinen müssen
und zwar habe ich einen sachertorte ein
rezept bekommen
ich weiss weiter den namen nicht mehr
von der lieben zuschauerin
aber sie hat mir das rezept gegeben und
zwar hat sich das von ihrer verstorbenen
mama eben noch und backt das daneben und
ich soll es ist auch mal nach backen und
ich werde auch dieses rezept nehmen als
vorlage wenn ich meine sache torte mache
und wenn wir schon besser hat horten
sind bin ich ja eigentlich schon in wien
denn ich möchte dort auch ein paar tage
hin bevor wir auf die gold messer nach
wien gehen
ich möchte dort eine originale echte
sacher torte essen und dann kann ich
auch dieses rezept machen und ich freue
mich jetzt auch echt schon wahnsinn
auf die messe in wien vor allem ist es
jetzt so vorerst mal die letzte station
vor der geburt was sich so öffentlich
noch machen werde das ist vom 11 bis 13
september und ab nächster woche könnt
ihr auch die karten bei uns im shop
vorbestellen und ich werde zwar nicht
viele kochshows wahrscheinlich machen
das wird dann im rat übernehme denn er
hat mir jetzt zwei drei mal schon zu
gucken dürfen aber der morath machen
dönerspieß aber auf jeden fall werde ich
da auch mit dabei sein und die tage mit
euch verbringen
und ja da freue ich mich jetzt schon
richtig drauf aber es wird wirklich sehr
anstrengend als ich steht dann auch
nicht so viel wie es letzte mal weil die
letzten zwei mal friedrichshafen haben
hamburg stand ich halt echt die ganze
zeit und das war also das kann ich jetzt
auch nicht mehr den ganzen tag stehen
und ja da freue ich mich schon drauf und
bitte euch wirklich noch mal drum mir
nicht mitzubringen bitte am besten auch
der murat nix und dass amira nix aber
man muss sich halt immer bedanken
das kann scheint auf jeden fall ja ich
glaube das war's eigentlich so ich
schenken euch im abspann noch ein paar
fotos mit hinterher und freue mich schon
wieder aufs nächste mal aus stimpfach
kommt bevor ich tschüs sagt ja genau
jetzt gibt gibt es noch das gewinnspiel
die auflösung und zwar wegen der
philadelphia aktion hatte ich ja die
drei sachen von kitchenaid gewonnen also
die heavy duty den blender und das
kochbuch und jetzt möchte ich das im
anschluss gleich verlosen hier vor mir
steht jetzt die kitchenaid heavy duty
die es zu verlosen gab und ich muss
sagen ich finde gewinnspiele eigentlich
immer ganz doof weil immer nur einer
gewinnen kann
aber ich finds natürlich sehr schön dass
ihr alle für mich abgestimmt hat und das
immer so viele mitmachen wenn es ein
gewinnspiel gibt was ich aber
andererseits jedoch total schade findet
weil ich auch gerne
also diese aktivitäten auch hätte wenn
es eben grad netten gewinnspiel gibt
aber auf jeden fall gibt es eine
glückliche gewinnerin
und zwar war das jetzt alles per
losverfahren also alles zufallsprinzip
alle hatten die gleiche chance und zwar
hat gewonnen sabine curio aus langerwehe
und zwar über ihren facebook account
herzlichen glückwunsch komisch zu finden
wie immer in die frau hätte ich echt
komisch aber ich habe natürlich auch 80
prozent frauen 20 prozent meiner mutter
hatte sie schon so soll die
wahrscheinlichkeit größer dass eine frau
gewinnt und du gewinnst dieses diese
küchenmaschine die kitchenaid idiotie im
wert von 1000 euro
ich bin fast schon ein bisserl neidisch
denn das ist sogar digittrade ich selber
nicht mal habe ich habe dann im
hintergrund die etwas kleinere und die
hier ist natürlich auch wunderschön vor
allem sehr groß und du hast jetzt genau
eine woche zeit die ich bei mir zu
melden am besten über facebook
hinterlasst einfach einen gästebuch als
gästebucheintrag hinterlasst einfach
einen kommentar auf meiner chroniken
beitrag und dann kann ich dich eben
kontaktieren und das nächste mal gibt es
dann die den blender zu gewinnen den
kitsch länder
das ist jetzt der kleine mit dem man
auch supertolle smoothies und shakes
machen kann
aber das gibt es dann einfacher im
nächsten gewinnspiel das was ist das
echte appenzeller berlin bieber gefüllt
wahrscheinlich aber der moment hat auf
der ces ist monatelang gab selten so
lange
lange selten so was okay er schmeckt
einfach grandios
wer weiß woher das muss es gibt mir eine
mail schreiben nämlich weiteren
kommentaren ich brauche eine ganze kiste
ich weiß zwar etwas farbe anscheinend
was der lecker aber auf jeden fall einen
schiffes zu schauen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bis jetzt gehen
wir zum kindergeburtstag